happen i want to get serious now
so you put out the ep
then um surferosa doolittle
um bossa nova and then tromp lemon and
then
what happens why did you break up um
[Music]
you know you know it just
we weren't we weren't happy anymore
there was just tension
you know yeah there was just just this
massive tension and
and uh yeah i couldn't stand it anymore
really
after a while it was uh
yeah it was it was it was bad really
because i always wonder that like how
can you can't just
talk it out tension
oh a talk yeah no all getting us in a
room and going
tell we we we were
socially inept we never talked about
anything
we just didn't you know yeah who's that
david lee ross said
you know you want to break up a band two
words band meeting
yeah right banned a meeting that means
it's over
well yeah yeah so then you break up and
then
how long will you because i just
remember it being
over a decade right longer than that
that you were
yeah broken up how long about a decade
yeah about 10 days 10 years yeah and in
that because i'm just so curious about
this because i know a lot of bands break
up
but what do you do you talk to them in
the 10 years or you just
stay completely silent just with charles
and uh because i record on his solo
stuff
all right and uh david right
yeah and kim kim i i
there's nothing there's no bad blood we
just don't
talk after the tour like i haven't
talked to david
since we left australia um
yeah it was like the corona thing was
just raging yeah yeah and we just got
the hell out of there
and um uh charles maybe once
uh has i haven't talked to her it's just
it's just what bands do it's normal it's
normal yeah yeah
it's a normal you think you think that
you would call each other a day yeah
how's how's the baby you know what i
mean yeah how you
are you doing the yoga you guys don't do
that
no you guys you guys show up at it's
like work
yeah it's work mates yeah yeah if i
worked at radio shack could we brought
up radio shack yeah is radio shack still
around
maybe maybe a bankrupt yeah and i'm and
i'm working with a crew of people
on our off days we probably wouldn't
talk
exactly yeah that's what it is but you
guys there's love there though
yeah there is yeah yeah there's mutual
respect and all that you know but it's
just
you don't think about it yeah like
jordan peele that's exactly good i
was on my tv with jordan for how many
years i was on matt tv with him for
five or six years that's a long time and
then you know
that he did key and peel and this and
that then he won his academy award
and he texted me once every other month
back and forth
how's it going this and that but it's
not like we talk so i get it
but i love him dearly i love everyone
from mad tv
deeply if i saw them in the streets
i would give them a hug what nothing our
garden
not it's a neighbor's gardener who's
doing his is that driving you crazy no
it's not driving me crazy
but joy what did you do in that 10 years
um
i i uh i tin foiled all the windows
[Laughter]
i really did i fell in this deep
depression
right i've always had it you know i've
always had in the road but
but but that it was too much time and i
stood in it
yeah and uh yeah yeah
my wife at the time said what are you
doing he's like
i don't i don't i think blackout
curtains are expensive
yeah i thought it was totally normal
yeah yeah yeah
i thought it was genius it is genius
that's what i did in college when we
were broke we did foil yeah yeah yeah
yeah well i locked myself in there wow
yeah yeah and i stumped too i mean i
i i i really did i was it was
now i look back at it wasn't normal and
we're similar in many ways where
we we dipped in the the drugs
yes and you know i want people to know
that the way i know joey i know joey as
a
sober guy yeah and i too am sober and
we've connected in that way
that's our the foundation and um
what is i mean because i know that when
you got sober
it was a difficult transition like all
of us right yeah
like if the first year was tough yeah
yeah yeah it really is like you don't
i didn't know what to do with my days
yeah
you know what i mean that's what i knew
was normal that's
oh maybe i did have a problem
everyone else knew but me yeah but but
but then i started to know
and then i really knew when i was just
puzzled what the [ __ ] people do
yeah when they wake up what do you what
do you do well you know
what did we have lunch even lunch
i i i get i got i felt
bad by not ordering a drink yeah
when i go out you know and i go to these
places and
uh yeah yeah yeah anyways well we're
talking yeah you
i'd go to these places and they know me
and they would
i'd start here in the shaker right when
i enter the door
yeah it's like oh [ __ ] no i can't no i
don't do that
yeah and they just go what it's like
but they respect it yeah it's it's it's
an odd thing
it is it's uh but you know
let me be honest it's i don't do it
listen do i miss it does it feel good to
get high
yeah but i just can't live
you know i mean number one when i'm
smoking weed or doing whatever i'm doing
i can't live in the moment
i can't connect with people around me i
can't um
i'm just not in god's light it's hard to
explain
but you know by being sober there's a
spiritual
element to my you know me sobriety
and it's like and you know i've been
sober off and on since i was 17 years
old
so i know what it feels like to be
present and mindful and to be
you know mean clear you know and it's
like i just can't i
dude don't i i'm like anyone else when i
go to a mexican restaurant
i want a martinis margarita margaritas
market market
i can't say certain things all right and
i'm tired of being
sorry george [ __ ] shamed by white
people because i can't speak your
language correctly
all right i i
mis i mix up pronouns and someone told
me that the filipino language tagalog
doesn't have pronouns it doesn't so my
mom
is so i go like he's dad you just said
he she to hit yeah you know yeah yeah we
can't assume
she's a girl i'll be a boy not at least
not at this time
you know what though if you really think
about it the filipinos got that right
that part right in their language like
they just don't refer
to anything as male or female it's just
like
like if it's just a person yep like
there's no
male female so my mom it's always this
is how she says it oh you know darling
so he she went to the she just covers
her basis and she says he
she just in case it's a he or she